ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS RULINGS
OF JUDGES WHO FRUSTRATE THE
PUBLIC WILL AND EXCEED THEIR
AUTHORITY.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION,
JUST OUTSIDE THE WASHINGTON DC,
HE'S AT CPAC.
ALL RIGHT, NIGEL, YOU'RE THERE
AT CPAC WITH ALL THOSE JUDGES.
IF WE DON'T KEEP THIS MOMENTUM
GOING, WE WON'T GET JUDGES ON
THE COURT AND A LOT OF HIS
AGENDA CAN BE UNDONE.
WHAT WAS YOUR SENSE FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH?
>> IT'S ALL ABOUT THE MIDTERMS.
HE'S ACHIEVED AMAZING THINGS.
HE SAID TODAY THAT HE KEPT MORE
PROMISES THAN HE ACTUALLY MADE
DURING THE ELECTION CAMPAIGN,
WHICH WAS A GREAT LINE.
BUT HE'S DOING HIS STUFF.
HE GOT TAX REFORMS THROUGH JUST
BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT HE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE KEEPS MAJORITY OF BOTH OF
THOSE HOUSES IN THE MIDTERM.
I TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I SHARED A PLATFORM WITH HIS IN
MISSISSIPPI BACK IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
HE WENT AROUND THE COUNTRY
SPEAKING TO BIG AUDIENCES.
HE'S A WONDERFUL MOTIVATOR.
BUT TOLD I SAW A PRESIDENT WHO
WAS USING HUMOR, WHO WAS LIGHT,
WHO EVEN TOLD A JOKE AGAINST
HIMSELF.
AND I THINK IF TRUMP GOES AROUND
THE COUNTRY IN THE RUNUP TO
THESE MIDTERMS AND PERFORMS
ANYTHING LIKE HE DID TODAY AT
CPAC, HE WILL KEEP HIS MOMENTUM
GOING AND THAT'LL LEAD THROUGH
TO EVERYTHING HE NEEDS TO DO.
>> YEAH, YOU AND I RAN INTO
EACH OTHER THIS MORNING AND YOU
WERE NICE ENOUGH TO AGREE TO
COME ON THE SHOW TONIGHT.
IT'S SO AWESOME.
BUT IT WAS RIGHT BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT SPOKE.
I SPOKE AT AROUND 9:00.
AND I WAS TRYING TO -- AND I
KNOW YOU SAID THIS AS WELL.
YOU HAD SUCH A GREAT SPEECH.
THAT WE NEED TO BE HAPPY
WARRIORS.
WE'RE WINNING ON ALL THESE BIG
ISSUES.
THE LEFT IS RESISTANT.
IT'S TEDIOUS.
NOBODY WANTS TO BE ON THAT RIDE.
>> CAREER POLITICIANS ARE AS
DULL AS DISH WATER.
WHY?
THEY'RE ALWAYS BEING SAFE.
THEY'RE NOT DOING THIS OUT OF
PASSION, PATRIOTISM, CARING
ABOUT PEOPLE.
THEY ARE DULL, HUMORLESS,
WITHOUT ANY REAL PERSONALITY.
AND WHAT SPARKLED TODAY FROM THE
PRESIDENT WAS HIM BEING HIM.
AND I WAS VERY, VERY PRIVILEGED
TO MEET YOU THIS MORNING, BUT I
WAS ALSO VERY PRIVILEGED TO MEET
THE PRESIDENT JUST AFTER HE CAME
OFF STAGE.
AND I SAW A MAN ABSOLUTELY AT
THE TOP OF HIS GAME.
I GET THE FEELING THAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS NOW REALLY ENJOYING
WHAT HE'S DOING.
YOU'RE SEEING HIS REAL
PERSONALITY COMING OUT.
AND I'VE WATCHED THIS AND I'VE
FOLLOWED THIS AND BEEN PART OF
THIS, EVEN THOUGH I'M A
FOREIGNER, BUT MY VIEW IS WITH
TRUMP, THE BEST IS YET TO COME.
>> YEAH.
HE REFERRED TO THE NEXT SEVEN
YEARS, CLEARLY PUTTING TO REST
THESE IDEAS HE'S NOT GOING TO
RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU THE
MEDIA'S REACTION TO THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HOUR-PLUS-LONG
SPEECH.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THIS MORNING AT CPAC, HE
COVERED AT LEAST 31 DIFFERENT
TOPICS.
BUT IT TOOK ALMOST 40 MINUTES
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT BEGAN HIS
CONVERSATION ON THE PARKLAND
SCHOOL SHOOTING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE TIME IN
HIS CPAC TODAY TO ADDRESS HIS
BALD SPOT.
>> I MEAN, THE PRESIDENT WAS
SELF-DEPRECATING
SELF-DEPRECATIN
SELF-DEPRECATING, WHICH THE
MEDIA HAD COMPLAINED HE NEVER
WAS.
I HOWLED.
WE WERE WATCHING IT IN OUR HOTEL
ROOM.
WE WERE JUST SCREAMING.
IT WAS SO FUNNY AND IT LIGHTENED
THE MOOD.
BUT THEY LITERALLY CAN NEVER SAY
ANYTHING POSITIVE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE DOES.
EVEN IF HE PUSHES THE GUN
CONTROL MEASURES, THEY SAY IT'S
NOT ENOUGH.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
NO, OF COURSE THEY DON'T.
AND WITH REAGAN IT WAS THE SAME.
THEY NEVER FORGAVE REAGAN FOR
WINNING ONCE AND THEN TWICE AND
THEY KEPT AT IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH HIS PRESIDENCY.
BUT HE GOES DOWN IN HISTORY AS
ONE OF THE GREAT PRESIDENTS.
AND I DON'T THINK IT MATTERS
ANYMORE WHAT CNN SAY OR THE NEW
YORK TIMES WRITES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED.
PEOPLE OUT THERE, ORDINARY,
DECENT ORDINARY PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THEIR LIVES, DO THEIR JOBS, PAY
THEIR TAXES, OBEY THE LAWS,
BRING UP THEIR FAMILIES, THEY
DON'T CARE ANYMORE WHAT
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS TELLING
THEM.
THEY MAKE UP THEIR OWN MINDS.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE PROGRESS HAS LEFT THEM
BEHIND.
AND IT'S ALMOST NOT WORTH
ENGAGING WITH THEM OR GETTING
DEMORALIZED OR DISTRACTED BY
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING OR THE
CONSTANT RESISTANCE.
MOVE THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD,
GET GREAT LEGISLATION PAST, DO
THE STUFF HE'S ALREADY DONE AND
THEN SOME.
I WANT TO SHOW A POLL ON SCREEN,
US SATISFACTION WITH WORLD
STANDINGS.
HIS 13-YEAR HIGH.
14% POSITIVE RATING.
2017 IT WAS 32%.
2005 IT WAS 48%.
THAT'S THAT GALLUP POLL.
HOW ARE WE BEING VIEWED, DO YOU
SENSE, INTERNATIONALLY?
AMERICANS ARE HAPPY WITH HOW
THEY THINK WE'RE BEING VIEWED BY
THE REST OF THE WORLD UNDER
TRUMP.
AT LEAST IT'S GONE UP.
BUT THAT'S GOOD NEWS CONSIDERING
WHERE THEY PREDICTED HE WAS
GOING TO TAKE US.
>> LET'S BE MAYOR
>> LET'S BE MAYO
>> LET'S BE FAYO
>> LET'S BE FAIR
>> LET'S BE FAIR,
>> LET'S BE FAIR, O
>> LET'S BE FAIR, OBA
>> LET'S BE FAIR, OBAMA
>> LET'S BE FAIR, OBAMA W
>> LET'S BE FAIR, OBAMA WAS
>> LET'S BE FAIR, OBAMA WAS A
DISASTER.
AND EVERYONE SAID THAT TRUMP ON
THE WORLD STAGE WOULD BE AN
EMBARRASSMENT, A DUMMY, HE
WOULDN'T KNOW HOW TO BEHAVE.
RIGHT FROM THAT FIRST SPEECH
THROUGH TO DAVOS WHERE HE
DELIVERED THE LINE, "AMERICA
FIRST BUT AMERICA NOT ALONE."
HE DID IT BEAUTIFULLY AND PEOPLE
UNDERSTOOD IT.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH, HE HAS
BEHAVED ON THE INTERNATIONAL
STAGE WITH HUGE DIGNITY, WITH
GREAT CONFIDENCE.
WHEN HE WAS IN BEIJING WALKING
AROUND, I THOUGHT HE WAS ABOUT
TO PUT A BID IN TO BUY THE
PLACE.
>> THAT WOULD BE NICE.
WE NEED THAT TO HAPPEN.
HE'S ACTUALLY THE FIRST
PRESIDENT TO ADDRESS THE CHINA
THREAT IN A SUBSTANTIVE WAY OR
TRADE AND NOT AFRAID TO SAY SO,
WHICH IS FANTASTIC.